audrey du rpr jacques chaban-delmas
exclus de la direction du mouvement
jacques chirac critique la majorité et
le président de la république marée
noire pourquoi antifer le seul grand
port pétrolier français est il installé
dans la manche le tiercé à longchamp
dans lord 7 8 2 madame mademoiselle
monsieur bonsoir nous verrons cette
actualité dans quelques secondes si vous
le voulez bien auparavant
je voudrais vous rappeler que depuis
quatre ans maintenant aucun journaliste
n'a plus filmer à l'intérieur du
cambodge
et bien ce soir pour la première fois
nous avons reçu de ce pays fermé à
double tour je devrais même dire à
triple tour quelques images certes elles
ne montrent pas l'essentiel
mais par le simple fait que nous
puissions vous les montrer elles sont ce
soir significative
ces images ont été tournées il y a
quelques jours par nos confrères de la
télévision yougoslave invité au cambodge
ils se sont rendus sur les lieux
présumés des combats qui depuis
plusieurs mois opposerait les khmers aux
vietnamiens les images symboliques je
vous le disais car elles sont les
premières
regardons les ensembles un khmer rouge
la frontière vietnam au cambodge yen à
70 kilomètres de phnom penh près d'un
gros bourg takeo ces soldats khmers
rouges sont filmées pour la première
fois par des occidentaux
depuis que le cambodge est coupé du
monde ces occidentaux les voici
ce sont des journalistes et diogo cela
très peu d'image mais d'après ce que
nous savons mon confrère eu beaucoup de
difficultés à les tourner témoins ces
quelques plans de takéo grosse bourgade
vie de toute présence humaine alors p6
grouillante autrefois
quelques secondes d'image seulement
demain nous espérons vous montrer à
notre film sur le cambodge des images
cette fois ci en provenance de nos
peines nos peines une ville de près de
deux millions d'habitants il ya quatre
ans et qui n'est plus habitée
actuellement semble-t-il que par une
cinquantaine de milliers de cambodgiens
après l'intense période politique que
nous venons de connaître avec les
élections législatives les français
qu'ils soient simples citoyens ou bien
une politique souffre en ce moment ainsi
monsieur giscard d'estaing après le
sommet de copenhague s'est rendu à
courchevel quelques jours à la montagne
en attendant le conseil des ministres de
mercredi aujourd'hui toute la famille
présidentielle
chaussé les skis une longue promenade en
montagne coupée par un déjeuner dans un
petit village une journée sans politique
donc pour le président de la rép
pourtant aujourd'hui en politique on
attendait le congrès du rpr monsieur
jacques chirac a obtenu le soutien des
militants rpr à propos de la réforme des
statuts du mouvement
le leader du rassemblement aussi obtenu
le soutien de son parti lorsqu'il a
défini la politique qu'entend des
désormais mener le rpr face au
gouvernement
un congrès qui se termine donc bien
daniel brême pour le maire de paris mais
qui a tout de même montré que tous les
gaullistes n'était pas d'accord avec
monsieur jacques chirac et notamment à
propos de l'exclusion de monsieur
chaban-delmas des instances dirigeantes
du mouvement
mais c'est à dire que cette motion a été
votée par 92,4 % c'est un score alors
que celle qui concernait le soutien à
monsieur chirac
obtenez 99,24 % des voix c'est à dire
que les 12 cents militants ont pesé de
tout leur poids quand même pour la
discipline du parti où il soutient donc
massif des militants pour la politique
mais on a beaucoup parlé cet après-midi
lors de ce congrès de l'incident disant
plutôt qu'un 6 dans des échanges
aigres-doux qui ont opposé monsieur
olivier guichard et gaullistes
historiques à monsieur willy c'est à
dire que monsieur diffèrent sur un ton
très calme et au nom de la presque
totalité des parlementaires a fait appel
à la fraternité a dit au nom des 31 ans
de gaullisme vous qui avait tant fait
pour le parti monsieur chirac ne
ternissait pas votre image et sur un ton
de colère contenue monsieur chirac a
répliqué à la porte de versailles comme
à la porte de pantin comme pendant la
campagne électorale
y avait deux grands absents comme
jacques chaban delmas par ailleurs il a
été élu avec les voix les plus anti
gaulliste que nous connaissons ce n'est
pas ainsi que je conçois le gaullisme et
la salle lui a fait une ovation
le reste je crois que vous allez pouvoir
l'entendre dans quelques instants
mais là encore les militants on peut
cette fleur
dans ces deux discours de ce matin de
cet après midi des discours plutôt
musclé monsieur chirac a énuméré ses
griefs à l'encontre de la majorité à
savoir que le rpr était considéré comme
un empêcheur de réforme est également
comme un obstacle à d'éventuelles
évolutions politiques et là le président
du rpr a notamment accusé
je cite le président de la république de
rechercher pour gouverner au centre une
coalition sociale ou centriste pour
exclure les gaullistes de la majorité
aujourd'hui nous ne demandons rien sinon
qu'on nous rende notre juste part de la
victoire
nous demandons aussi que cette victoire
ne soit pas gâchée certains nous disent
qu'il faut savoir la dominer c'est à
dire infléchir notre politique partys et
pactiser avec nos adversaires en quelque
sorte nous excuser un peu de les avoir
battus tout arrangement tout
renversement d'alliance toute
compromission avec les programmes qui
ont été nettement rejeté les 12 et 19
mars serait une trahison de la volonté
populaire est un manquement à la
conception de la démocratie qui aspirent
depuis vingt ans la cinquième république
bien vous avez noté de l'amertume du
thon de monsieur chirac qui face à ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des agressions
caractérisées à fortifier a retiré le
mouvement autour de lui invitant les
militants et les parlementaires à beaune
à menait désormais la bataille sur les
thèmes gaullisme idée qui at il dit à
plusieurs reprises seront les armes du
rpr il prévient du reste sans périphrase
le gouvernement que la cohabitation sera
plus que difficile à l'avenir si le
pouvoir veut entraîner le rpr hors des
chemins qu'il a lui-même traces dendre
de notre attachement aux institutions de
la vème république
je ne sais quel soumission
inconditionnelle
chaque projet de loi chaque initiative
gouvernementale sera par nos juges est à
la mesure de nos principes nous
approuverons quand nos convictions nous
le permettront nous refuserons quand
notre conscience tout le commandera pour
nous c'est la seule véritable loyauté à
l'esprit de la vème république
voilà pourquoi je vous le répète nos
idées seront nos âmes
voilà pourquoi je vous invite à les
porter autour de vous pour les faire
mieux connaître
ne vous imaginez pas que la tâche sera
passé car demain les sirènes de la
division chanteront de plus belle à vos
oreilles
j'en appelle à votre fidélité
demain on vous expliquera que
l'intelligence et souplesse et
l'intransigeance sottise
j'en appelle à votre courage demain on
vous dira que la volonté de changement
excuse tous les abandons et quand
maintenant l'essentiel vous bloquer les
réformes
j'en appelle à votre gaullisme source du
renouveau français et du véritable
changement
demain au nom d'une prétendue
clairvoyance historique
on cherchera à dissoudre notre pays dans
un ensemble plus vaste inféodés à tel ou
tel superpuissance
j'en appelle à votre amour de la patrie
j'en appelle
à votre idée de la france vous avez donc
suivi ce congrès du rpr aujourd'hui
est-ce que après avoir écouté ma
réaction
vous avez vraiment l'impression que tous
les militants du appert sont prêts à se
mettre sur certains projets de loi par
exemple en marge de la majorité écoutez
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si c'est la rupture effectivement et
certaines interventions comme celle de
monsieur guéna qui parlait de nos
adversaires de droite pour la majorité
pouvait le laisser croire
mais je crois que surtout monsieur
chirac a voulu donner un avertissement
c'est un peu le chiche
si vous dépasser certaines limites alors
nous passerons la frontière ce qu'il
faut quand même noter c'est que derrière
ces barbelés ses fortifications
il a entraîné bon gré mal gré les
parlementaires et donc il faudra
attendre les premiers votes c'est à dire
d'ici une semaine pour savoir de quelle
manière les choses se dérouleront la
peur n'a pas un peu aussi changé de
nature bien écoutez je serais tenté la
de vous dire que oui parce que
aujourd'hui est né un parti entièrement
dévoué à un chef qui n'hésitera pas le
cas échéant à l'essai sur la route
les gaullistes historiques car il a
l'appui du parti etc ceci pactise avec
le président de la république il est
certain que leur éviction peut arriver
alors je me demande également s'il faut
pas voir dans ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui le premier acte de la mise
en place d'une campagne pour faire par
exemple de monsieur chirac candidat aux
présidentielles de 1981 mais c'est peut
être encore un peu tôt pour moi
attendons maintenant de voir comment les
leaders de l'autre mouvement de la
majorité l'udf ont entendu monsieur
chirac aujourd'hui monsieur jean-luc
annuel était ce soir il est encore
l'invité du club de la presse d'europe
numéro un et pour le président de l'udf
et le rpr souffle tout simplement d'un
sentiment j'avais assez connu dans la
république on cale ses ministres
jamais le premier ministre ait aucun des
représentants politiques dont je fais
partie n'a déclaré que nous voulions
construire une coalition socialo
centriste entière père
ceci fait partie des rêves ou des
cauchemars je souhaite qu'à joue les
socialistes ou des socialistes
ceux-ci mériteraient également un
commentaire comprenant que monsieur
mitterrand a fait une erreur
fantastique de stratégie en liant le
destin socialiste à celui des
communistes pour constater finalement le
naufrage de cette illusion
je souhaite qu'à un moment donné d'une
évolution qui sera sans doute encore
longue il se trouve des socialistes pour
cesser d'être simplement contestataire
mais pour apporter à la majorité un
supplément de fortes
enfin vous me dites toujours les
gaullistes et les socialistes mais le
général de gaulle les a appelés dans le
passé
après la libération après son retour au
pouvoir en 58
est-ce que l'idéal d'un rassemblement
c'est de se recroqueviller outre
s'élargit toujours dans le domaine
politique mais en changeant de côté
cette fois l'opposition maintenant chez
les socialistes comme chez les
communistes cette période post
électorale suscite bon nombre de
réflexions pour l'un des inspirateurs du
crs monsieur pierre guidoni
le parti socialiste doit maintenant
durée et pour durer il doit se décider à
fonctionner comme un vrai parti un vrai
parti et puis pierre guidoni
c'est une organisation où les militants
s'expriment où les congrès débat tu
décides d'une ligne politique et la
modifie site élite si cette fille molly
politique est démenti par les faits pour
pierre guidoni havre est parti c'est une
organisation où la direction élus et
responsables de la politique de ses
succès certes mais aussi de ses échecs
du côté des communistes si une certaine
controverse existe au sein des cellules
ou bien des fédérations la direction du
parti reste ferme sur ses positions pour
elle henri malberg du comité central le
réaffirme est aujourd'hui dans cette
lutte contre la grande bourgeoisie le
parti communiste a dû malheureusement
passé beaucoup de temps à lutter contre
un partenaire qui alimentait lui même la
grande bourgeoisie en argument contre
les réformes nécessaires et contre son
allié d'hier que le parti communiste
français ne porte aucune responsabilité
dans l'échec de la gauche écrit henri
malberg signifie qu'il a lutté de toutes
ses forces pour assurer la victoire pour
le changement voilà pour les dossiers
politiques de cette journée de dimanche
un dossier encore bien chargé vous
l'avez constaté
en bretagne les hôteliers et tous les
bretons sont dans l'expectative du moins
dans cette bretagne du nord où le mazout
a remplacé l'eau et où les plages de
sable fin n'existe plus que sur des
cartes postales les hôteliers attendre
ils se demandent si leur saison est
définitivement perdue ou s'ils peuvent
encore sauver les meubles pour sauver
les meubles
il va falloir deux choses il faudra
d'abord que les côtes soient rapidement
nettoyées
près de sept mille volontaires ou
militaires s'y emploie un travail de
titan un travail de longue haleine et
puis il faudra aussi que les candidats
aux vacances ne succombe pas à la
tentation d'aller ailleurs pour les
bretons ces vacances de printemps qui se
déroule actuellement seront un test
après cette marée noire
tous ceux qui ont été choqués et ils
sont nombreux par ce qui se passe depuis
un mois sur les côtes bretonnes
m les pétroliers en accusation et il est
vrai que l'implantation des ports
pétroliers peut parfois surprendre mais
c'est parfois difficile aussi de les
mettre ailleurs ainsi antifer est le
port pétrolier qui peut recevoir les
plus gros bateaux des bateaux de 500
mille tonnes 600 mille tonnes et peut
être bientôt des bateaux d'un million de
tonnes 5 fois la cargaison transportée
par la moco qualité et bien antifer
c'est l'extension du bord du lot et ces
superpétrolier pour arriver devant donc
naviguer en manche non loin
quelques cuves de stockage une immense
digue d'un kilomètre et demi de long et
deux appontements antifer c'est cela un
port entièrement artificiel démesurée et
dr avec ses 30 mètres de fond c'est le
seul port français capable de recevoir
les pétrolières 500 mille tonnes mais
antifer c'est l'extension du port du
havre est donc ce terminal pétrolier
oblige les supertankers entrer dans la
manche a passé à quelques kilomètres des
côtes
à ouessant et au cap de la sig
actuellement la moitié du pétrole
importé en france arrive en manche
puisque la vente y faire assure à lui
seul 40% de notre travail
inauguré en 76 ce port a été conçu il ya
à peine 10 à l'époque d'autres
localisations étaient possibles
notamment à bresse le pendentif et rend
définitive assure enfin le pendu av
assure un trafic qui représente environ
le dixième du trafic total dans la
manche rotterdam à lui seul importe
environ 200 millions de tonnes de
pétrole
en supposant même que nous français nous
ayons transférer notre trafic à brest
pour éviter la le transport de pétrole
dans la manche il rencontre fallu que
les hollandais les belges des allemands
les anglais en fassent autant
mais entre brest et antifer il y avait
quand même une question de coût oui il y
avait effectivement une question de coût
alors si tout le monde avait été
d'accord pour effectivement à éviter la
manche
tout le monde aurait été dans les mêmes
conditions de compétition mais si nous
français nous avions consenti cet effort
alors que les autres ne l'aurais pas
fait nous aurions été dans la
compétition internationale dans une
position très désavantagé combien de
bateaux peuvent en même temps accosté
antifer actuellement nous avons deux
postes antifer il n'est pas prévu de
d'augmenter la capacité du port et c'est
bien suffisant actuellement aussi
suffisant pour assurer les
approvisionnements pétroliers de la
france suffisant pour les
approvisionnements sans doute pour la
sécurité ce n'est pas sûr car le trafic
des pétroliers n'est pas régulier et ils
sont parfois obligés d'attendre à
quelques kilomètres seulement des côtes
bien sûr en matière de surveillance de
pilotage et aide à la navigation 30 y
faire et très bien équipée
reste enfin que ce port qui est
encouragé le trafic pétrolier en manche
a coûté très cher 750 millions de francs
dont la moitié environ financé par
l'état et sa rentabilité en raison de la
crise du pétrole demeure toujours
incertaine mardi prochain les forces
israéliennes se retireront en partie du
sud liban c'est au moins ce qui avait
été annoncé vendredi avant-hier par le
chef de l'état major israélien haut
responsable des forces de l'onu
installés au liban un retrait qui sera
limité et qui pourrait même être
retardée dans le sud du liban la
situation reste en effet très tendue et
il ne se passe pas de jour où des coups
de feu se sont échangés soit entre
palestiniens et israéliens
soit entre palestiniens et forces de
l'onu soit enfin entre chrétiens
conservateurs et casques bleus dans ce
conflit du sud liban on a aussi appris
que les israéliens contrairement aux
engagements qu'ils avaient pris avec les
états unis il ya quelques mois ont
utilisé lors de leur dernière offensive
des bombes à fragmentation
ces bombes à fragmentation on les
appelait des bombes ali pendant la
guerre du vietnam avaient été livrées à
israël par les américains avec des
conditions d'emploi très précises
israël avait l'autorisation de les
utiliser dans un seul cas le cas d'un
conflit général ou sa sécurité auraient
été mises en jeu ces événements du
sud-liban tu ne semble toutefois pas
mettre en péril les espoirs de paix qui
s'étaient fait jour dans cette région du
monde depuis le mois de décembre
faire preuve de patience vis-à-vis de
monsieur begin est un devoir c'est ce
qu'a déclaré ce matin le président
égyptien anouar el sadate
malgré toutes les garanties que je lui
ai donné a poursuivi le chef de l'état
égyptien
monsieur begin est toujours dans un état
de grande peur il est disposé à aller le
plus loin possible dans l'entente et
dans l'accord sauf en ce qui concerne la
rive ouest du jourdain
une déclaration dans l'ensemble assez
conciliante donc une déclaration qui ne
ferme pas la porte en tout cas avant le
nouveau voyage que doit faire monsieur
weissmann le ministre israélien de la
défense au coeur ne pas perdre le
contact c'est l'objectif de monsieur
weidmann le ministre la défense qui va à
nouveau rencontrer le président sadate
il ya également du côté égyptien la
volonté de ne pas rompre les ponts
recevoir à nouveau un dirigeant
israélien alors que le sud liban n'est
toujours pas évacué
c'est être en contradiction avec
certains discours au caire
destiné donc à l'opinion arabe en fait
les négociations quoique difficile se
poursuivre mais pourquoi le président
sadate pêcheurs t-il discuter avec
monsieur weissman on a l'impression
qu'il ya une sorte d'amitié qui s'est
lié entre les deux hommes parce que
affirme-t-on monsieur wizman et un sabre
à c'est-à-dire un israélien né en israël
donc plus orientale le courant passerait
mieux qu'avec monsieur begin qui
représente la rigidité des premiers
migrants venus d'europe centrale mais
alors de quoi vont-ils discuter on
assiste dans certains milieux à
jérusalem que les positions en ce qui
concerne le retrait du sinaï se sont
assouplies et que l'on arrivera à des
concessions territoriales youtube
par contre la grande difficulté reste
toujours le problème de la cisjordanie
l'egypte et du président sadate ne peut
pas s'engager dans un processus de paix
avec israël sans avoir obtenu au moins
une déclaration d'intention d'un retrait
de cisjordanie comme les israéliens ne
sont pas encore prêts à faire cette
concession majeure
cette rencontre n'est qu'il étape sur un
chemin difficile semé d'embûches qui
mènera peut-être un jour à la paix
grâce à vous êtes notre correspondant
permanent en egypte comment les
égyptiens réagi style à ces négociations
qui finalement n'en sont pas et qui
traîne enfin ce ne soit pas tout à fait
des négociations mais ces relations qui
se sont établis entre rysman et sa date
de son sont pas établis à la place des
négociations en attend toujours la
négociation qui ne manquera sans doute
pas s'engager et deux hommes il faut en
parler un peu c'est vrai dès leur
première rencontre ils ont reconnu l'un
et l'autre qu'il y avait entre eux des
atomes crochus c'est très important
parce que on raconte pub dans
l'entourage de sa dette au caire que
weizmann aurait confié au président
égyptien son intention de s'installer
alexandrie d'une fois que la paix sera
signé bon alors on n'est pas encore bien
sûr a acheté la maison
mais d'ici là tous les relations un peu
l'étroite permettent et sincère en tout
cas permettent de ne pas couper les
ponts qui sont établis entre jérusalem
et le caire et c'est très important
il semble que ce maïs man soit
maintenant le saut liens qui unissent de
la vie fait le coeur ben oui dans l'état
actuel des choses ces frais mais sa date
ils trouvent plusieurs 7e' raison de
satisfaction d'abord c'est lui cela lui
permet de perpétuer si vous voulez en
quelque sorte
l'impact sur ses initiatives de paix
ensuite personne d'un côté comme de
l'autre devront prévert ont continué à
se voir
et puis enfin on mise un peu chez les
égyptiens sur les difficultés
antérieures relatives d'ailleurs que
rencontrent menahem begin et on pense
qu'à un moment ou un autre
le premier ministre actuel israélien
devra soit se montrer plus compréhensif
soit céder sa place et sceller sa place
post on imagine t'on experton peut-être
avec bad et on pense qu'à ce moment
algérie vannes sera un partenaire plus
compréhensif plus ouverts aux thèses
arabe alors dans l'état actuel des
choses donc le contact continu c'est
très important et de part et d'autre on
pense que finalement c'est l'essentiel
héros shawn aussi d'ailleurs
certainement merci le pape paul 6 a
évoqué ce matin en s'adressant aux
fidèles place saint-pierre l'enlèvement
de monsieur aldo moro l'espérance est
opportune dans la douloureuse situation
de l'italie a déclaré le souverain
pontife dans cette angoisse dus à des
événements tristes et menaçants sur l'
enquête menée par la police pour
retrouver le président de la démocratie
chrétienne italienne a rien de neuf ce
soir
selon certaines rumeurs toutefois un
nouveau message le cinquième des
brigades rouges auraient été adressés au
gouvernement et dans ce message monsieur
aldo moro aurait dicté au gouvernement
de monsieur julien dray au type toutes
les sous à la forme d'un ultimatum les
conditions mises par les brigades rouges
pour sa libération
une tentative de coup d'état va échouer
cette nuit en somalie un groupe
d'officiers et de soldats auraient tenté
de renverser le gouvernement du général
siad barré cette tentative de putsch
aurait fait de nombreuses victimes en
iran après plusieurs semaines
d'agitation et de nombreuses
manifestations d'opposition au
gouvernement de téhéran des
manifestations qui se sont soldées par
de très nombreuses victimes
ce sont aujourd'hui les partisans du
shaq qui sont descendus dans la rue à
tabriz manifestation organisée par les
autorités mais aussi soutenu par
certains chefs religieux avant de
terminer ce journal je voudrais demander
de m'excuser une seconde
un simple coup de téléphone
bien avant de terminer ce journal je
vous le disais une fois n'est pas
coutume nous reviendrons dans le tiercé
dans quelques instants sur le tiercé
dans quelques instants maison le
terminer ce journal en chansons en effet
vous en souvenez probablement les films
de james bond pardon on tue il y a pas
mal d'années déjà un très grand succès à
la fois en france mais aussi dans le
monde entier et dans l'un de ses films
et s'appelait goldfinger une chanteuse a
acquis la célébrité c'est elle qui
chantait le thème du film goldfinger et
elle s'appelle shirley sur les bassins
est arrivé hier à paris elle va donner
quatre concerts au théâtre des champs
elysées du 21 au 24 avril c'est une star
internationale
elle a traversé toutes les modes depuis
20 ans et elle se retrouve toujours bon
an mal an en tête des ventes de disques
dans le monde
son seul peut être des faux petit défaut
peut-être et bien n'aime pas beaucoup
les journalistes pourtant pour antenne 2
elle a fait hier soir quelques
confidences à georges bigot alors je
vous laisse en sa compagnie pour
terminer ce journal je vous rappelle
simplement que notre prochain journal et
à 22 heures mais avant de retrouver sur
les bassins est
nous verrons le terrain
depuis 1962 sur les bassins n'est venu
que deux fois en france son troisième
séjour
elle compte bien profiter de ce que les
anglo saxons depuis très longtemps
apprécie le plus dans notre capitale
avant tout je compte mangez bien mangez
nulle part au monde on ne peut
satisfaire sa gourmandise aussi bien
qu'ici je ne fais pas de régime
et puis ce n'est pas tout paris sait la
haute couture et j'avoue que je suis
très sensible au chic français
d'ailleurs le monde entier s'y laisse
prendre
côté professionnel peut-être vais-je
découvrir de nouvelles chansons
j'aime beaucoup les mélodies qui met la
voix en valeur
j'ai déjà chanté gilbert bécaud ou
charles aznavour et claude françois
et
oui
mais il est très difficile d'allier la
vie de famille et le show-business
je fais de mon mieux car j'attends
beaucoup d'importance à l'éducation des
enfants et à l'ambiance chaleureuse qui
doit régner dans une famille mais que
voulez vous je chante depuis l'âge de 16
ans c'est ma vie j'espère en avoir
jamais à choisir entre mes deux
vocations car elles ont autant
d'importance
je suis anglaise je vis en suisse mais
je connais très bien l'amérique là je
pense que l'amérique depuis qu'ils
offrent encore le plus de possibilités
aux jeunes de réussir leur vie
mais malgré tout c'est très dur
non
charles habas c'est en avril au théâtre
des champs-elysées à paris pour quatre
concerts uniquement rapidement les
résultats du tiercé nous n'avons pas
encore les rapports
il fallait jouer pour l'emporter
aujourd'hui le 7 le 8 et le 2 7 8 2 les
rapports bien sûr dans notre dernière
édition avec avec l'autre c'est une
course qui s'est couru si je puis dire
sous le soleil un temps printanier qui
cependant ne va pas se poursuivre la
météo nous annonce des nuages pour
demain et même quelques averses au nord
d'une ligne bordeaux metz au sud de
cette ligne
il y aura encore quelques nuages quant
aux températures elles resteront
sensiblement semblable à celle
d'aujourd'hui
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée il est 20 heures et 27 minutes
à 22h50 22h55 vous retrouverez hervé
claude pour notre dernier journal de ce
dimanche quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée